non pas des crises la crise
ce qui distingue ce film d autres sur
alexander mcqueen c'est qu'il combine
les archives personnelles du couturier
et des entrevues avec ses proches du
jeune décrocheur qui achètent des tissus
avec ces chèques des aides sociales
à son entrée à la maison givenchy de
paris
je le film dévoile un être singulier il
puise son inspiration dans l'histoire
l'architecturé la robotique pour
réinventer ces défis qu'ils faisaient à
l'époque c'était hyper innovateur hyper
dans la technicité dans le dans tout le
long le travail dans la courte c'était
génial c'est un génie à l'époque il est
je pense me laissera toujours des vidéos
amateurs permettent de revivre en
accéléré le naufrage intérieur dans
l'exemple de mes couilles c'est un être
très tourmentée qui souffrait de
dépression qui consommaient beaucoup de
drogue aussi donc il s'y retrouver dans
une espèce de 1 un cercle vicieux aussi
finalement la drogue lui permettait de
travailler fort lui permettait de voir
plus clair un certain niveau mais il
entraînait encore plus dans sa
dépression et donc
il y allait vraiment pas bien et c'était
transposer dans ses oeuvres ce le succès
précoce la pression de créer jusqu'à 14
collections par année et le poids de la
célébrité ont achevé le créateur il
s'est enlevé la vie en 2010 à 40 ans
quand même il y avait de la chance les
gars c'est puis je pense qu'il pouvait
plus voir ça y était dépassée de tous
dans ce portrait intime de yambo noté de
peter et elle dit l'enfant terrible de
la mode fascine encore petit score de
croiser les gants
evelyne charrues et radio canada
montréal